the idea is completely unoriginal the
idea that teachers are the central lever
in education is sort of obvious the idea
that we have to respect them and we
can't respect them simply by paying lip
service to respecting them is also
completely unoriginal many many people
have said the country and the education
system will not improve until teachers
are paid a decent wage so the idea is
sort of common sense it didn't come to
me in a flash I think it's out there in
the culture the only sort of challenge
was how to implement it so when I was in
the classroom teaching sixth grade for a
couple years and then eighth grade one
of the things that really appealed to me
was the whole idea of public charter
schools because public charter schools
essentially free teachers and free and
administration from the constraints of a
large bureaucracy and allow creative
individuals to create a school that they
think will produce better results and
produce better more educated kids than a
traditional school so it's a very
entrepreneurial venture the idea of a
public charter school it really gives
people who think they know what they're
doing and maybe we don't but the
opportunity to at least see if we can
create a school that is outstanding I'm
freed from the constraints of a large
bureaucracy and the flip side of course
that appealed to me is charter schools
at least in theory are really supposed
to be held accountable in a way that
publix that traditional public schools
are not public charter schools really
have to meet certain goals in order for
their charter to be renewed and that's
also very appealing because you can
actually see whether you've been
successful or not in New York State if
you're writing a charter you typically
get a document from the state that says
here are the goals that you have to put
in your charter there's not much choice
the goals center a lot around
attendance standardized test results
parent teacher student satisfaction and
I think all those are important though I
will say this I think the emphasis on
standardized tests represents a
relatively low bar if kids are not
passing the New York State English
language arts exam then certainly the
school is doing something wrong however
if they are passing that exam I don't
necessarily think that means the school
is a great school there are a lot of
other factors that go into whether the
students are learning and whether the
school is excellent just to give one
example standardized exams have a very
difficult time assessing whether a
student can write which in my view is
one of the most important if not the
most important skill that emerges after
12 years of schooling you much more
easily can measure that through
something like a writing portfolio where
you get a sample of a kid's writing
every two weeks in different disciplines
and sort of see over the course of the
year what was the student writing in
September and what was the student
writing in June and assessing that for
content for form for grammar all of that
to me is a much more robust measure of
whether the school is being successful
and the students are being successful
than a standardized tests which are
important in my view but represent a
relatively low bar one of the things
that we that we're trying to do is is
really have the teachers get a lot out
of the school environment as well I'm
obviously that's a focus of the school
the idea that a school is not just for
students it's also a place where adults
work and I think if you have a school
that buys into the mythology that
teachers are sort of sacrificial lambs
who should do everything in service of
the children and should negate
themselves ultimately you hurt the kids
and ultimately you hurt the school
environment so we're trying to create a
school environment where teachers
themselves are viewed as learners and
their own growth as learners and as
people is developed one of the ways we
do this is we have an annual summer
development institute for six weeks we
there are no kids teachers spend that
time reflecting on their own practice
another example is that every five years
or so the teachers are required to leave
the school for a year and take a
sabbatical a mandatory sabbatical what
do they do during that year there's no
requirement they don't even have to
connect it in fact we don't want them to
connect it to what they're doing in the
classroom and how it's going to make
them a better teacher we want them to go
skiing for a year if that's what they
want to go get an art history masters if
that's what they've always wanted to do
get a job another job so really we're
valuing their own growth as people and
they're allowed to have interests
outside of teaching